Michael Keaton walked away from playing
Batman in Batman Forever back in 1995.
that move came a full six years after he
first donned the cape for Tim Burton in
the then genre defining film Batman the
film proved a massive hit with fans in a
financial Juggernaut at the box office
as did the pairs deliciously divisive
follow-up Batman Returns though Keaton
didn't immediately exit Batman Forever
he certainly began to rethink his
involvement once Burton wasn't on board
apparently he knew he was done after he
read the Rewritten script and Keaton's
own words what was it about three that
you just didn't like sucked yeah
felt so passionately that he reportedly
turned down a 15 million dollar payday
to reprise the role